let f of x be equal to the square root
of 4x minus 3 and let c be the number
that satisfies the mean value theorem
for f on the closed interval between 1
and 3 or 1 is less than or equal to x is
less than or equal to 3.
what is c
so let's just remind ourselves what it
means for c to be the number that
satisfies the mean value theorem for f
this means that over this interval
c is a point x equals c is a point where
the slope of the tangent line
at x equals c so i could write f prime
of c so that is the slope of the tangent
line when x is equal to c this is equal
to the slope of the secant line that
connects these two points so this is
going to be equal to
see the slope of the of of the secant
line that connects the points three f of
three and
one f of one so it's going to be f of 3
minus f of 1
over
3
minus 1. and if you wanted to think
about what this means visually it would
look something like this
so this is our x-axis and this is
one
two actually let me spread it out a
little bit more
one
two
and three
and so you have one comma f of one right
over there so that is at the point one
comma f of one
and we could evaluate that actually what
that's one comma one right
so that's going to be the point one
comma one and then you have the point
three comma let's see you're gonna have
four times three is twelve
minus three is nine so it's gonna be
three comma three
three comma three
so maybe it's right over there
three comma 3. and it might look the
curve might look something like this
so it might look something
like that
so if you think about the slope of the
line that connects these two points
so
this
line
that connects those two points all the
mean value theorem do that in a
different color all the mean value
theorem tells us
is that there's a point between 1 and 3
where the slope of the tangent line has
the exact same slope so if i were to
eyeball it it looks like it's right
around there
although we are actually going to solve
for it
so
some point where the slope of the
tangent line is equal to the slope of
the line that connects these two
endpoints and their corresponding uh
their corresponding function values so
that is c that would be c
right over there so really we just have
to solve this so let's first just find
out what f prime of x is and then we
could
substitute a c in there and then we can
evaluate this on the right hand side
so
i'm going to rewrite f of x
f of x
is equal to and i'm going to write it as
4x to the minus 3 to the one-half power
it makes it a little bit more obvious
that we can apply the power rule and the
chain rule here so f prime of x f prime
of x is going to be the derivative of 4x
minus 3 to the one-half with respect to
4x minus 3 so that is going to be
one-half times 4x minus 3 to the
negative one-half and then we're going
to multiply that times the derivative of
4x minus 3 with respect to x well
derivative of 4x with respect to x is
just 4 and the derivative of negative 3
with respect to x well that's just going
to be 0. so the derivative of 4x minus 3
with respect to x is 4. so times 4. so f
prime of x
f prime of x
is equal to
4 times 1 half which is 2
over the square root of four x minus
three four x minus three to the one half
would just be the square root of four x
minus three but it's a negative one half
so we're gonna put it in the denominator
right over here and so
f prime of c we could rewrite this as 2
over
the square root of
4c minus 3. and what is that going to be
equal to
that is going to be equal to
let's see f of 3 we already figured out
is three f of one we already figured out
is
one
and so we get three minus one over three
minus one well that's gonna be two over
two which is equal to one
so there's some point between one and
three
where the derivative at that point the
slope of the tangent line is equal to
1. so let's see if we can solve this
thing right over here well we can
multiply both sides of this by
4c
by the square root of 4c minus 3 and so
then we are going to get
we're going to get 2
is equal to the square root of 4c minus
3. all i did is multiplied both sides of
this by square root of 4c minus 3 to get
rid of this in the denominator
and so let's see now to get rid of the
radical we can square both sides and so
actually let me just show that so now we
can square both sides so we get
4 is equal to
four c minus three
add three to both sides seven is equal
to four c
and then divide both sides by four i'll
go right here to do it you're going to
get c is equal to seven fourths c is
equal to
is equal to seven
over four which is equal to one and
three fourths or we could view this as
one
point
five so actually the c value is a little
bit closer i hand drew this it's closer
to about right over there on our diagram
and actually that looks pretty pretty
clo that actually looks pretty good i
just hand drew this curve so it's
definitely not exact but anyway
hopefully that gives you a sense of what
what's going on here we're just we're
just saying hey the mean value theorem
gives us some c where the slope of the
tangent line is the same as the slope of
the line that connects
3
1 f 1 and 3 f of 3.